hey guys how's it going welcome back to
another fun cooking video today we are
going to learn how to make a burrito now
this video is inspired by the new grande
burrito that they have for a limited
time at Dunkin Donuts and you guys know
that Dunkin Donuts is one of my most
favorite places ever if you guys are new
here you might have missed the video or
my sister and I actually slept outside
for the grand opening of the Santa
Monica Dunkin Donuts and think the line
so if you want to take note of - its
grand opening Tuesday right now it's
about four and you also might remember
last year when I tried to recreate one
of their other recipes the actual
burrito from Dunkin Donuts they do use
all real ingredients and of course they
have breakfast all day and that to me is
a dream come true so what you said that
a red pepper and roasted fire roasted
peppers are different okay good
cuz I've got a red pepper and I've also
got fire roasted peppers fire mmm so for
our ingredients we're gonna need a
tortilla we got some Jack cheese we've
got fire roasted red peppers rice beans
jalapenos onions egg corn but I forgot
to buy it so let's just act like it's
sitting right here on our red pepper
this is red pepper by one specialty is
actually making eggs so I'm gonna start
up this pan I'm gonna get it nice and
nice and warm so if there's one thing
that I know I know when you're making an
omelet you need to start with the eggs
so let's get our eggs and you go in you
go in you go should I use a couple more
they're starting to cook really quickly
and that's scaring me so that our first
ingredient for an omelette is eggs
voila
okay next up I'll add some jalapenos put
a little of those in there that's a
water onions what that's that's not
gonna fit anywhere I think my
proportions are slightly off I'll let
all the tough beans in you go this
actually looks nice and some Jack cheese
dude this actually looks freaking
fantastic less rice and well let's just
like so wait did you cook the rice no I
just took it out of the box
oh it says Made Easy but it's not not
that easy I just took it out of the
container
mmm a little crunchy
so Jenna what you're saying is you don't
want if you want to bite of this or what
I mean I'll still eat it like oh it's
actually looks really good doesn't look
anything like an omelet where's my
tortilla here's a problem these are
really small this is not gonna be a
crummy burrito this is gonna be an
accidental mini grande burrito but well
what happened are you in here this is
not gon day oh you think I just made a
taco I'm trying too hard to make it but
it's not staying together like a burrito
let me think about it I'm gonna try it I
can't why you even eat this this is not
a burrito this isn't as thick
Oh God hey no clumping I've got my IRA
got room to figure this probably happens
I am so glad Dunkin Donuts is now in
California here's the actual grande
burrito there's two versions there's a
sausage and a vegetarian leave me a
comment down below if you're vegetarian
because I actually used to sort of be a
vegetarian but now I'm not so I'm going
to enjoy this sausage one first it's
like a little baby
I'll just cradle it in my arms oh that's
good I just want you to know that it's
10 p.m. right now and I'm having
breakfast toast for the fourth time
today
I'm so happy let's try the vegetarian
that's well over I also note yourself
don't wear lipstick one eating burritos
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope that you enjoyed this video let me
know what you guys would like me to
attempt to cook next and let me know if
you guys hit up Dunkin Donuts and what's
your favorite thing is there and also
like I said before let me never
vegetarian and how that's working out
for you I'm gonna go and enjoy this I
started with cooking show so I couldn't
just have an excuse to eat food all the
time anyway this videos about our
Twilight Princess
let's open